WHIT, WE WILL TRY IT AGAIN.
WHAT DO YOU SEE ON YOUR PROPERTY
ON YOUR RANCH?
>> SO, WHAT WE SEE, BRIAN, WE
ARE A LITTLE BIT NORTH OF THE
RIVER.
BRIAN: GOT IT?
>> THE BORDER WITH MEXICO.
WHAT WE END UP SEEING IS WE SEE
AND TYPICALLY WHAT WE HEAR ABOUT
ON THE NEWS IS PEOPLE CROSSING
THAT BORDER.
BUT ESSENTIALLY THERE IS ANOTHER
BORDER THAT IS ABOUT 50 MILES TO
THE NORTH AND WE CALL IT THE
INTERIOR CHECK SYSTEM OR THE
INTERIOR CHECK POINT.
SO, ONCE ALL THESE PEOPLE GET
ACROSS THE RIVER, THEY THEN NOW
HAVE TO MAKE ANOTHER JOURNEY
ACROSS TO THIS NEXT.
BRIAN: KIND OF LIKE A SECOND
BORDER INTERIOR BORDER.
AND YOU SAY ONE OF YOUR
NEIGHBORS FOUND ABOUT 100 BODY
OVER THE YEARS ON THEIR RANCH.
WHAT AGES ARE THEY?
WHAT ARE THEY UP TO?
>> NO, THAT’S CORRECT.
WE HAVE SEEN BODIES.
WE DON’T FIND THIS MANY.
IT’S ALL BASED ON WHERE YOU ARE
GEOGRAPHICALLY LOCATED AND HOW
PEOPLE TRAVEL AND WHERE YOU ARE
AS TO WHERE THE BODY ARE FOUND.
WE FIND MORE LIKE TWO TO THREE.
I MEAN, I DON’T KNOW, THAT’S
STILL ENOUGH.
BRIAN: ABSOLUTELY.
>> SOME PEOPLE ARE FINDING UP
TO, ARE YOU KNOW, LIKE YOU SAID,
A NEIGHBOR OF MINE HAS BEEN
FINDING CLOSE TO 10 A YEAR FOR
THE LAST 10 YEARS.
BRIAN: SO YOU SAY THAT THESE ARE
MEN BETWEEN THEIR 20’S AND 40’S
NEVER QUALIFY FOR ASYLUM.
>> RIGHT NOW IT IS.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
>> RIGHT NOW IT IS, BRIAN.
IT’S NOT ALWAYS THAT WAY.
IN FACT, RIGHT NOW WE’RE SEEING
HARDLY ANY CHILDREN OR WOMEN
BECAUSE OF EVERYTHING THAT’S
GOING ON ON THE RIVER, THOSE
PEOPLE AREN’T HAVING TO MAKE
THIS JOURNEY.
THEY ARE BEING, YOU KNOW, THEY
CAN CLAIM ASYLUM, THE WOMEN AND
CHILDREN CAN AND THEY ARE BEING
BUSED PLACES RIGHT 2340U6 THERE
IS A REAL KIND OF A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF A DANGEROUS SITUATION.
YOU HAVE SINGLE MEN MALES COMING
UP.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT’S JUST --
THERE IS A SENSE OF FEAR THAT
EXISTS DOWN HERE ALL THE TIME.
IT’S A TERRIBLE SITUATION.
BRIAN: IT’S NOT FAIR AND THAT’S
WHY YOU ARE LOOKING TO TRY TO
PASS A LAW TO TRY TO STOP THIS
SMUGGLING TO PUT MORE TEETH IN
THE LAW TEXAS TO DEAL WITH
SMUGGLERS.
WHAT DOES THAT LAW SOUND LIKE?
WHAT DOES IT READ LIKE?
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
IT’S A STATE LAW.
IT’S HB 687.
AND WE’RE REAL FORTUNATE THAT WE
GOT A HEARING FOR IT YESTERDAY.
AND WHAT IT DOES IS IT BASICALLY
HELPS PENALIZE SMUGGLERS AND
PROVIDES PROTECTION FOR
IMMIGRANTS.
IT ALLOWS OUR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO DO, INSTEAD OF --
IT HELPS IMPROVE THE PENALTY ON
OR STRENGTHEN THE PENALTY ON
TRESPASSING.
BRIAN: GOTCHA.
>> FROM A STATE LEVEL AND GIVES
OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
ABILITY TO DO MORE WITH THE
SITUATION.
BRIAN: GOTCHA.
WHIT, WE LOOK FORWARD TO
FOLLOWING THAT EVERYONE LOOKS AT
THE RIVER AND BORDER AND THERE
IS A SECOND BORDER YOU JUST